get 12 weeks of the spectator in print
and online for just 12 pounds
and you'll also receive a complimentary
six months of digital access to the
telegraph
for free
[Music]
hello and welcome to the spectators book
club podcast i'm sam leith the literary
editor of the spectator
and my guest this week is kate
summerscale a former colleague
and a brilliant historical non-fiction
writer
whose newest book is the haunting of
alma fielding
a true ghost story which is about a sort
of
instance of poltergeist activity
haunting
ghostly manifestation possible demonic
possession
taking place in 1930s croydon
um okay welcome tell us first of all
why you gave it that subtitle a true
ghost story
because most people today would think
well it can't be
well i enjoyed the sort of questions
that a subtitle raised about
truth and ghosts and it most ghost
stories
most published ghost stories are
fictional
in form and genre but actually in the
1930s i discovered
while researching this story there was a
great vogue
for true ghost stories anthologies of
trugo's stories were published
and there was a fascination with the
connection between ghosts and science
spiritualism
and so the idea of truth and ghosts was
not as
contradictory as it might seem now no i
was going to say i was thinking the
books contemporary readers
or the people reading this contemporary
story would read that subtitle
differently wouldn't they yes
so i was sort of playing with that with
the sort of period
resonance of it which i i hoped would
emerge for the reader
while reading the book but also to draw
attention to the fact that
um this is a non-fiction book it's
and to say a ghost story would be
misleading
in that it would imply that it was a
novel
and so this was um it was a true one
because it's
it's a researched ghost story which is
which took place in a
particular time and place i think that
kind of often surprised me how you
stumble on your stories i mean do you
sit and sort of
read these yellowing newspapers through
until you see something and think
that's it i mean what point do you know
you've got another book
well it's different every time in this
case i had a
feeling i'd like to write about the
supernatural and about a haunting
and i started by reading late victorian
newspapers and and books that i thought
might give me
clues as to what would be a good story
to pursue
the period i found most surprising was
the 30s because there was this huge
flourishing of interest in in ghosts and
hauntings and a great plethora of
hauntings throughout britain
and this took me aback and so the
feeling of
surprise and mystery um and my own
curiosity about what was really going on
here
was the thing that gave me the sort of
energy or momentum to think this might
be worth pursuing
and that if i pushed at it i would i
would find something out about
the time as well as the subject matter
well let's start start with subject
matter itself i'll be sort of delicate
to try and avoid spoilers too much
because
well i'll maybe let you guide how much
you said the story but can you sort of
tell us who was alma fielding
and how did her story start in this
sense
she was an ordinary um apparently
ordinary
working-class housewife in croydon who
was married with a teenaged son and a
lodger
in her terrace house and she rang the
newspapers one day in february
1938 to report a poltergeist in her
house
who everyone else in the house testified
to having seen in action
also throwing things across the room
smashing glasses and crockery
and by the time nandor fodor this ghost
hunter from
the international institute for
psychical research turned up
there was an astonishing array of broken
damaged bent objects the house had been
sort of beaten up
in effect the newspaper men apparently
saw this
supernatural activity as well and so did
fodor and his colleagues so
it was on the face of it a really
astonishing
sort of evidence of of the paranormal
yeah and the house or seasons have had
an inexhaustible supply of crockery
it described me it was that elmer's
husband les was a builder
they needed to have a lodger in the
house to make ends meet
and yet they seem to have an
extraordinary amount of stuff
you know ornaments pots and pla pans and
plates and glasses every kind of wine
glasses brandy glasses tumblers
so there was a weird something going on
already to me that in this working class
home there were so many
objects and such a kind of gleeful or
furious destruction of these objects
that
in itself struck me as as curious and
interesting
whether or not there was a paranormal
force behind it
and why was it that you know have your
first instinct on finding your
crockery and exploding and your eggs
flying across the room
you used to go to the sunday pictorial
does that tell us something about the
times yes she
rang them saying she was terrified there
were things going on she couldn't
explain
and the context for this is that sunday
pictorial was running a series on the
supernatural
and had encouraged readers to write in
she obviously didn't have the time to
send a letter it was much too
urgent an occurrence with their stories
and they received more than a thousand
responses from the public this
poltergeist attack in croydon came hot
on the heels of another in
bethnal green which had excited the
attention of the bbc
in various newspapers so poltergeist
really seemed to be
all over the place and they were in the
papers
and so alma not thinking it was a matter
for the police exactly it's quite
difficult to know what to do with a
supernatural alarming
supernatural event um she she went to
the press
and what do you think was sort of going
on in terms of
this like explosion of poltergeist
activity is that a form of sort of mass
hysteria
i think there are probably always
specifics to it
about individual households and
individual people
but certainly the prevalence of
poltergeists
at that time seemed to me to
bear a very close relationship
to the general anxiety abroad in england
then about the imminence of war
people like the fieldings alma and her
husband and son the husband had served
in the last war been badly injured
still suffered from trench dreams and
the sun was likely to be called up in
the next
and in the meantime that every week the
papers were reporting on the
aggressive maneuvers of hitler and
mussolini and
the country was preparing itself for war
you know there were air raids wardens
being appointed schools commandeered
and so this um the ghosts especially
these violent ghosts which is what
poltergeists were really rackety
um noisy destructive
jittery ghosts seemed to me um
a sort of a bleak expression of certain
kinds of anxiety that were in the air
and tell me about this fodor
you're sort of mis mr witcher for this
book where does he come in what's his
attitude i mean kind of
interested in this line he seems to
tread between skepticism
and and belief yes he's a very
beguiling character to me um and the way
i came across his story originally was
by reading his book about
his hunt for the poltergeist and the
case this case sort of
transformed his attitudes but already at
the beginning of 1938
he was both desperate to find a ghost he
longed to believe
in ghosts and to find evidence of them
he was very open to the idea and his job
was to be a ghost hunter for this
institution
which was trying to find scientific
proof of the supernatural
he was trained as a lawyer he'd worked
as a journalist
he was quite skeptical and
suspicious in a friendly way of a lot of
the claims that were made by medians
and he was gaining a bit of a reputation
as a
ghostbuster having exposed various
mediums
which was not what he wanted to do but
he just kept kept fighting
out inadvertently finding evidence of
fraud when he went looking
for evidence that ghosts existed and he
was edging towards as a sort of freudian
rather than spiritualist explanation for
where these supernatural phenomena
came from which seemed to me very of its
time
and in the way that it melded psychical
research with psychoanalytic thinking
but also very sort of suggestive and
intriguing about the people
um who he studied i think that's really
interesting about the book is that
this idea of ghost hunting and
ghostbusting
sort of threads through so many of the
themes of the time
i mean you know we now sort of see
anything to do with the supernatural as
hokum
but at the time there seems to have been
a really earnest sense that this might
be undiscovered science
and to discover is a quantum physics and
so forth
we're also feeding into this this idea
that there might be a scientific
explanation is that a fair summation yes
there seemed to have been
i mean it was always a sort of fringe
activity but nonetheless reported quite
enthusiastically in
and with a lot of curiosity in the press
that psychical research
that maybe as fedor said maybe
there were forces out there that we just
hadn't learned to
channel and harness as we once hadn't
electricity
and there was a great deal of
open-mindedness towards the possibility
that people could
communicate telepathically and there
were the likes of
so oliver lodge who was one of the
pioneers of radio
was a great spiritualist having lost a
son in the first world war
um and he certainly saw parallels
between
the invisible forces of the spirit world
and the invisible forces
of the known natural world
they referred to the um this area as the
supernormal because it wasn't seen as
sort of
supernatural as in unnatural it was just
natural forces that hadn't yet been
understood and a lot of scientists um
were interested in this subject and the
institute for which fodor worked was a
strange and um interesting mixture of uh
of spiritualists and and scientists and
there's a peculiar side plot in which
he's in the process of suing
is it sort of psychic news or socratic
magazine called something like that
for accusing him of not believing enough
in ghosts
yes paul fodor he was sort of caught
between being so
into the eyes of some he was sort of
helplessly gullible
and in others he was a terrible sort of
materialist skeptic
who was bringing all these filthy
freudian ideas to bear on
on this sort of pure spiritualist
material so psychic news didn't like him
because he was exposing mediums
and he was becoming more and more
interested in the possibility
that supernatural events were created by
the unconscious mind
rather than the spirits of the dead and
they
accused him of being cruel to mediums
and obsessed with sex
and he sued them saying this put his um
you know professional reputation in
doubt and
jeopardized his career at one point
there's a lovely bit in the
story where i think the judge says you
know we should remember that this is a
man who traveled to the isle of wight to
talk to jeff the talking mongoose
yes and i think um fodor relished the
the comedy of some of his um
[Music]
some of the cases he worked on so jeff
the talking mongoose um was quite
famous in the mid-30s much written about
in the press
he was supposedly the familiar of a
teenage girl on the isle of man whose
parents
also had seen jeff and hurt him of
course because he talked
and he not only talked he was sort of
energetically insulted the family
at all times of day and night stole from
brought them gossip from the rest of the
island ate their chocolate
and butter and various islanders
said they too had had seen jeff and
heard him speaking so ghost hunters
among them harry price
and the editor of the listener magazine
went out in
search of jeff and fodor eventually went
and he stayed longer than
anyone else he spent a week in the the
cottage
where jeff supposedly lived he sent jeff
a letter
afterwards complaining about the fact
that even though he brought him
chocolate and other goodies jeff had
refused to appear for him
and castigated jeff and said he'd come
back if he promised to talk to him next
time but no jeff left him hanging
but that's saying he he found it
entertaining i mean there is a sort of
strand
i think you say somewhere that at
various points
you know it almost behaves like
vaudeville you know when
alma's performing because she's she
comes doesn't she just to stop
as it were performing or or
demonstrating her powers for various
members of the institute of psychical
research
that it acquires a sort of vaudeville
atmosphere that they start
you know it's they stop being scared and
start treating it as theater
to begin with it's all very sort of
creepy and weird in alma's house
but once she's invited to the institute
for further investigation of her powers
because it does seem everyone agrees
that the poltergeist seems to emanate
from her in some way
then the poltergeist turns into a kind
of genie or magician
and amma proves able to materialize
objects from thin air
as she walks around the sales room
closely observed by all the researchers
at the institute
and then they become impressed in a
different way by the sort of magical
powers that
she seems to to have and
and it is like a a sort of but whether
it's her or the poltergeist performing
for them bringing them gifts and uh
there is a really intriguing mixture of
the
entertainment going on and scientific
research
and these people who support the
international institute and attend the
science the seances
it's an enlivening kind of curious
dimension to their lives and um it's
it's sort of both experimentation
and entertainment there's a sort of
almost weird shadow play goes on isn't
that at various points
alma is in a trance and you're speaking
to alma's sort of spirit guide
because she goes doesn't she through
almost every different sort of psychic
manifestation from
producing objects to you know being
possessed by other beings astral
projection
she she apparently projects her body
invisibly through space from
croydon to kensington and back again yes
but yes she gets possessed by spirits
seemingly
who speak through her and sometimes the
things they say are quite convenient for
her alma as well in that they sort of
discourage the
researchers the spirit voices discourage
the researchers from
pressing her too much or making too many
demands of her they're very protective
of her in that sense
and you get the um the sense the
researchers are a bit
sort of uneasy suspicious they don't
know if they're being played with or or
not
there's a curious sort of power dynamic
that the power shifts
between alma is the sort of specimen who
they're investigating
and their sort of prized possession this
star medium who might
transform the study of psychic science
and her as somebody who who is possibly
manipulating
them as well as the objects that she
brings into the seance room
but then there's also there'll be
conversations had between
alma's spirit guide and the spirit guide
one of the investigators
there's a woman called eileen garrett
who was one of the most famous
mediums of the day and at one point
her spirit guide who's um called uvani
is interrogating alma's spirit guide who
is called brember i'm not sure
but everyone's sitting around solemnly
while these two spirit guides converse
one of them giving the other advice or
trying to ascertain whether
whether the other one is real or a
product of the unconscious mind
it's a book that sort of takes a turn
from you know a certain amount of kind
of high comedy and bathos
in you know i mean there's flying mugs
of boveril
some reason you know nothing involving
both real can seem all that spooky
but into something that's much more
sort of psychologically fraught and sort
of sad
did you sort of anticipate it going that
way did you see the trajectory of the
book as it gets more complex
shaping up or it was as you wrote it you
suddenly you realized that there was
something more here
yes as i wrote it really i was sort of
drawn to the story because it had all
those strands
of of something sort of serious and
and something that was sort of unsayable
at the time that was being communicated
through this supernatural
performance or phenomena and also to the
comedy
and to the silliness of some of it and
um
to the the lovely sort of imaginative
wild ideas that the whole
episode generated and but yeah as i
as i wrote it a more a clearer
trajectory emerged that
the play slipped into something darker
and it was as if everyone got out of
their depth
maybe all at the same time and that
something that was
that was playful curious manipulative
and sort of rich and funny became
much more sort of crueler there was a
sort of element of
sadomasochism that i saw emerging
and very dangerous you know
psychologically dangerous
and and that people started to really
worry
about um demonic possession and
psychological breakdown i mean there's
that sort of
hint of that which as you say towards
the end of the book you know
plays into things like carrie by stephen
king for example you know
that this idea that trauma
expresses itself in dissociative
identity disorder which expresses itself
in
you know stuff that looks like
possession or
ghostly activity do you think alma
believed that she was in contact with
something supernatural
i don't think she knew i yes i think she
believed that she might be
yes and i don't know which points and i
think that's for the
reader i do try to leave it open because
i think
that this is something depending on what
your own experiences
and beliefs are i think you'll read this
story differently
so try to leave it open for the reader
but i don't doubt that she was
frightened as well as as as fodor would
put it
mischievous so i think both those
those strands are there and i think one
predominates
at some points and one at the other and
i think eventually her own mischief
frightened her and the fact of um
deceit and manipulation maybe to sort of
turn back on her
and so i think she was she was genuinely
scared
yeah exactly what she was scared of how
much of it was supernatural and how much
of it was
as of her own psyche hard to know
those things are too internal and um and
i think that's for a
reader to to judge according to their
own way of
looking at the world how culpable do you
feel fodor was
i mean do you think he helped her or do
you think he sort of led her somewhere
more dangerous
well i think both i think he did make
her feel
special and valuable and heard
and gave her a forum and gave gave her a
stage
really in which she um sometimes
fictionally but played out sort of true
things versions of herself that were
otherwise unexpressed
and i think that her attraction to him
actually
sort of led her into some dark places
and i think he didn't um really know the
power that he was
wielding so i think it was dangerous
what he was doing i think his intentions
were good
and i think his um his reading of the
situation was
sympathetic and open-minded but
nonetheless
he was playing with fire and i don't
think either of them realized it yes do
you think his
his interpretation was sort of
essentially on the money
you quote extensively from sandor
frenchy
who seems to have been well ahead of his
time as a sort of authority on
on the effects of trauma yes that was
that was a fascinating thing that i
discovered while
while researching the book that
forensics work was not really known in
um in britain at the time
and was or in it it hadn't even been
published in english
but the key patient with whom he
developed his ideas
of trauma and dissociation and
in effect shell shock because he'd
worked with soldiers too
in the first world war became a friend
of fodors and pastor and
took part in the in the investigation of
alma
and this woman called elizabeth seven
and so there was this very direct human
link sort of
before even any of these theories had
been published in english
between forensics theories about
post-traumatic shock and the splintering
of the personality under a
traumatic stress and the theories that
fodor uh through elizabeth seven
applied to alma so um that was very sort
of intriguing to have those
ideas applied in this apparently
supernatural case
and i thought he was onto something not
just in the case of alma but some of the
other women
mediums the female mediums uh psychics
in his circle
that there was the dissociation might
well
in many cases reflect an inability to
keep the personality sort of
intact after a really shattering early
experience
am i right in understanding that that
idea of
dissociated identity disorder or
what used to be called multiple
personality disorder it's still quite
contested
in the field of psychology yes
absolutely i think it is
and i don't i think it's it's still a
very sort of um
questionable and the truth of it it's
almost like the supernatural or
something how you
understand the truth of it how you
interpret whether it's uh
what causes it or how much it's
fictional and how much it's factual
is still completely up for grabs as far
as i can see
now you do have which i mean the timing
of it's always sort of
too good but the historical record just
chugs along
in the background of this book what were
you
trying to do with that the move towards
the second world war and
you know i mean there's a very memorable
where you say i think you quote one of
freud's disciples saying that
cristal nacht was essentially a sort of
poltergeist incident
the psychic dissociation that you know
they in
germany had internalized its fears and
projected it onto its jewish population
and that
you know it seems very very ready
parallel
yeah i mean all that just emerged from
sort of reading the
newspapers and and histories at the time
next to this case the case came for
first i was just looking at the case and
then i kept seeing parallels with things
that were going on
outside and not just with
alma because what fodol's theory was
that um
the poltergeist was a real physical
force
but it was caused by a repressed
traumatic event
that generated this force suffer
unconsciously
so there was that which seemed to sort
of map on to various
fears and repression to repress dread of
the war that was coming or the war that
was passed
and then it because you save and to what
was going on in germany
but yeah you're right sort of neatly
enough uh strange
fodor himself was a hungarian jewish
emigre
he'd come to london via new york
but when he came up with these theories
about traumatic repression and the
supernatural and poltergeists
he so appalled his colleagues at the
international institute that they
expelled him
which seemed a very neat kind of symbol
for the expulsion of this sort of dark
material which was exactly what he was
talking about the way that people
project outside themselves and maybe
institutions and countries
too can project outside themselves
representative of their their darker
feelings
as a way of persuading themselves of
their rhythm
and yes to demonize and to scapegoat
and expel is exactly what his theory of
of poltergeists were really
surrealism also manages to just
perfectly
spread slide in yes
in april um 1938
matisse's first solo exhibition opened
in london and this was one of the weeks
i mean i try to follow quite closely for
most of the book probably two-thirds of
the book follows the four months of the
investigation of alma so fodor's
investigation
and so i paid quite close attention to
what else was going on in london at the
time
and this matisse exhibition caught my
eye
and i looked at the pictures that
featured in it
and they seemed such kind of bizarre
dream-like images and i realized they
drew on freudian ideas in much the same
way that fodor was drawing on them and
in much the same way
that he recognized much supernatural
experience seemed
to embody these bizarre juxtapositions
of the banal
and the exotic of the very violent
and apparently innocent domestic object
um and matisse can sort of the paintings
that he showed that month really
encapsulated that and seemed to me
that they almost illustrated the
poltergeist in the home in croydon
in their spirit and there's also i think
in the most
some of the matisse ones you describe
are these sort of dissected or
chopped up and objectified a sort of
blazing of a woman's body
and there is a sort of theme in here
about
women's bodies and their idea of
constraint
and the sort of odd
invasiveness and almost sort of
eroticized invasiveness
that is involved in the investigation
into alma
the whole business of the seance in
itself
you know from the 19th century onwards
was
um seems sort of very erotic in the way
that it allowed strangers to touch
and feel and smell each other in these
darkened rooms
and certainly the relationship between
fodor and alma seemed to me to have a
sort of an erotic edge in the way that
he
could touch her and
hold her supposedly in the interests of
science
sometimes with a slightly constraining
sort of
cruel edge to it but also sometimes
more tenderly more excitingly for her
and and so all those things i think were
at play there all she had to make use of
was her body as a means of expressing
herself or impressing others and that
is deployed to dramatic effect i won't
give too much away there but you know
she made full use and fodor's like
furious curiosity about
about her body and what she's doing and
the
surveillance and the attentiveness not
just of him but
all the researchers in the institute is
a very sort of heightened
almost melodramatic version of the
relationships between men and women
at that time she parades before them she
produces things
they watch her intently and with
fascination
and suspicion no it's an absolute stew
of these ideas
well i suppose just end by asking does
any small
itsy-weensy tiny part of your mind come
away thinking
you know what some of this may have been
supernatural yes
as often as not somebody says they have
seen a ghost
i haven't i think that also
like fodor i as i work
through this material i thought it
really isn't whether it's true or not
objectively true or not that matters
it's what it means to the protagonists
what it symbolizes what it expresses
so yes maybe and i don't think it would
transform
my interpretation of the story i don't
think that that is the decisive factor
whether there are real supernatural
forces working
through alma or not it's something that
is obviously very interesting to work
out what
what she did and didn't believe and what
was really going on
but it's the it's the messages within
these events that seem to me to be the
most telling
kate sanders girl thank you very much
listeners don't have nightmares
get 12 weeks of the spectator in print
and online for just 12 pounds
and you'll also receive a complimentary
six months of digital access to the
telegraph
for free